we welcome you back to cbs warnings
we're not talking about cows or moons
what we're talking about is the hit
broadway musical dear evan hansen have
you seen it it comes to the big screen
this month and ben platt returns to the
role that won him listen to this a tony
a grammy and an emmy the guy is that
good plaid stars is evan a high school
senior struggling with his mental health
a classmate's suicide and the pressure
of social media and in this scene evan
and his mother who's played by the way
by julianne moore have a very emotional
discussion about acceptance and shame
well they like me they like me i know
that that's very hard for you to believe
that they don't think i'm you know that
there's something wrong with me that i
need to be like fixed like you do when
have i ever said that oh my god wow i i
have to go to therapy where i'd have to
take drugs there's nothing wrong with it
there's nothing wrong with needing help
honey i know that there is and i know
that i'm a burden i'm the worst thing
that ever happened to you and i just i
just ruined your life okay no you
are the best thing you're the best thing
that's ever happened to me
i love that scene ben platt joins us
here in the studio hello ben platt hi
thanks for having me oh we're glad
you're here we're very glad you're here
you know i saw i saw ben platt on
broadway i saw dear evan hansen on
broadway two times and i was worried ben
if you would be able to take this and
capture it on the big screen did you
have the same kind of trepidation of
course you know there was a really
beautiful experience on stage and a kind
of a once in a lifetime opportunity and
um required a lot of me emotionally and
physically and mentally and i was really
proud of that chapter and so to reopen
something like that and you know on an
even bigger platform is certainly a very
scary thing but i think just the sheer
number of people that would have the
opportunity to see it particularly young
people was more than enough motivation
and that's what i'm excited about the
young people that get to see it because
it's coming at such a very dicey time in
our in our in our country where there's
a lot of mental health there's a lot of
anguish there's a lot of sadness and i
think there are so many messages and so
many
layers to this movie absolutely i mean
the two that always really stand out to
me particularly for right now the first
is probably the more obvious which is
you know isolation and loneliness are
more universal than ever particularly
for these young people who have been
stuck at home and who have missed the
social experience of school and who are
feeling trapped in their own minds and
in their own you know mental health
struggles and i think the movie is a
really beautiful reminder of our shared
humanity and the fact that we all want
to be connected and that regardless of
how we present we're all going through
something and i think that the other is
particularly in this age of you know
cancer culture and kind of very harsh
criticism and kind of finite criticism i
think it's a beautiful thing for young
people to see a character who makes a
big mistake who does something wrong to
not only understand where that's coming
from but also to watch someone like that
heal and find forgiveness from himself
and from others and move forward and
that you know we all by virtue of being
human beings are going to make
mistakes to know that he's not a hero
here no no it's you know he's a
complicated character and i think that
that's the kind of character that
represents humanity you know none of us
are heroes doing good things all the
time and yeah there is a duality in your
character that you capture there's a
strength and then there's also a
fragility um so one i just want to say i
commend you on that because that is all
of us whether we want to admit it or not
but going back to the broadway hit i i i
was privy to a conversation and
listening to you talk about how
capturing that emotional side of your
character
on a nightly basis was tough but you did
something unique um to tap into that
what was that totally so i mean i i
still really carried that over to the
film but i think you know whenever i'd
get to the theater on a day where it
felt
difficult to climb the mountain or to to
kind of do that whole piece because we
were doing it eight times a week i had
the privilege of reading
you know hundreds of letters that young
fans would send to the stage door to the
whole cast and to me in particular just
about the ways that the show had
affected them um and one in particular
that i keep with me to this day in my in
my room at home um was an anonymous
letter that that just said you know
because of this show i didn't let go um
and i think whenever you get you know
mired in your own anxieties or
apprehensions or in you know
people's negativity or criticism i think
reminding myself and and the whole
creative team reminding ourselves that
this piece really has the power to to
change young people's lives and to
remind young people that they are loved
and to that they're seen and that's
right they're not perfect and then
that's okay is that's a really wonderful
kind of fire under our butts to get over
the difficult stuff it's such an iconic
character and a character i think is
going to be with you for a long time uh
i am curious about the shoes
the evan hansen new balance shoes yes do
they live in the costume department or
do you have a pair at home i have them
so i i for our first ever console it's
so funny tony i never even noticed a
shoe to me it's like the signifier of
the character it's a very particular
high school look it always was to me
that the when i when we were first
figuring out how he was going to look
for the very first production in
washington my only real contribution was
that i remembered kids in high school
wearing these gray new balance and
something about those shoes felt like
him to me so the actual pair that i wore
in all three productions is also in the
film because i've carried them with me
and they've sort of been my little good
luck charm so they they now sit very
ripped up on my shelf
so
they're
i didn't even notice the shoes i noticed
the way you mold your body and the way
you twist and turned and you captured a
high school angst so beautifully thank
you do you see yourself in evan hansen
at all i do i think you know we we both
share you know struggles with anxiety
and i think we both are pretty fearful
like non-confrontational people and i
think
sometimes much like evan i can shy away
from more painful awkward difficult
conversations that can lead to deeper
connection and i feel like playing him
has and seeing what he goes through and
what could have been avoided if he was
willing to do the to to have those
conversations it encourages me to push
myself off of that cliff as much as
possible and plunge into those
situations because i know how meaningful
they can be i struggled with your
character though ben because i knew what
he did was wrong but on the other hand i
it gave the family
such hope and such joy that i almost
didn't want them to know the truth but i
knew the truth had to come out so i
found myself sitting there struggling as
i watched you i think that's what's
beautiful about the piece is that it's
it's ambiguous and it forces you to look
at yourself and what you might do in
that situation and i think there's not a
person who couldn't understand why
looking at this grieving mother you
wouldn't want to give her exactly what
she wants and seeing what evan is going
through and how alone he feels how
wonderful it would be for him to have an
acceptance with this family and have
somewhere to belong and it doesn't
excuse it and it doesn't condone it but
it it allows us to understand the
humanity of it and why he does it well
you've got the tony the grammy the emmy
all you're missing is uh the o word i
know he's in a movie now
that doesn't stand for oprah yeah we
have to go but the album is out now
right yes reverend yeah my second record
is out i'll be touring next year it'll
be really fun awesome stuff
congratulations on everything ben platt
thank you so much dear evan hansen opens
in theaters next friday a week from
today